hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play amnesia Justine okay um we
just uh we're two for three whoa on
leaving people alive I think so oh oh oh
no oh no
what will that perfect sphere bring
talking about the orb agree it's not too
late it will be the end of everything oh
is this where the darkness gets me dark
tat the tattered yellow King shall be
thrown suffer the trial through the
gates oh this is creepy from beyond it
comes they will borrow burrow waits they
who burrow waits beneath them sorry I
can read the Pipers will call for a
stupid dance death shall move across the
floor
why are Elias does to use dust as a safe
as a sore muse I don't know
it will be again it's coming Oh father
the beautiful pain skinless one is
waking up climb the highest tower spin
the wheels crank the engine okay I think
I think this is just a circle yeah good
I'm crying or someone else crying suck
it up lady come on we can do this
gluttony it pleases me lonely there
probably see what will that perfect okay
it's just repeating I think now pattered
yeah it's just repeating okay I gotta go
Oh like this I don't like this my
darlings the gates yeah oh man the
inside weight plummet through the
ancient city some of these things are do
playful it will be again it's coming I
don't like it whatever it is
can you wait stay alive I'll try you let
me Oh what is that Wow
watch what am I
okay what
wait what hey ho set moving oh it's a
trash compactor ha ha
gimme yeah upon you hardcover Onew bone
ah get in there get in there
what do I use what do we use bright
woman wood wood ha ha I need a metal I
need metal I need oh yeah get in there
get it baby
Walter closing it god damn it what are
you going with my metal go ho give me
the metal ok ok ok
oh my god I'm gonna die because it was
too stupid I'm too stupid to figure it
out I'm too different too stupid
oh oh
boom damn it oh ok I fail I fail oh oh
I'm so boned squished oh ok I failed
guys oh [ __ ] death is final balls yeah
jam it okay alright
oh wait what oh this was the best one
yet
so elaborate it's just too much what
enough of this Jesse what
wait ah it's an M night Shyamalan twist
I was just in the whole time
wait I didn't I didn't do that I saved
him I can't I save him
whatever okay okay here we go what okay
you're the boss
Justine lady okay
[Music]
apparently okay for it anymore
okay hey wow man I kind of want you know
I kind of wish I didn't do this just so
if you guys played it you wouldn't get
the spoiler that Justine is you the
whole time but wow that was short but
that really got me I thought I thought I
screwed up that last part but man that
was good
obviously was gonna be good because it's
it's frictional games it made it and and
they made it in like a few days I think
just because I read the story they were
all invited out to foul headquarters and
they just made it on a whim these guys
don't even work in the same country most
of them they all just collaborate over
the Internet and they all made the
entire game amnesia the Dark Descent
they made the entire game it was like
six of them I think without ever meeting
up and that's amazing I read that
article it was just like amazing to hear
something like that can happen and make
it game that good but anyway so amnesia
just seen great game great twist ending
better than name night M night Shyamalan
to do and yeah man that was good you
should go play it if you haven't played
amnesia and needs Justine or any of the
custom stories yet you have to do that
so just do it alright so once again
thank you guys so much
I always appreciate everything you do
special thanks to GLaDOS there alright
this was for the portal 2 things so I
appreciate every single one of you I
hope you liked my thousand subscriber
vid like I really do would do anything
for you guys just to show my
appreciation so a month other milestones
I'm gonna do more crazy stuff but all in
all thank you guys so much for watching
and I will see you in the next video bye
bye